alright it looks like we are now live
for the December oh there we go now I'm
seeing a live button would life rely for
the philosophy pop up for December
thought I'd have a little bit of a
different backdrop this time although I
stand here holding the laptop this
entire time he's in the City of
Milwaukee behind me we finally have some
snow it's about time by this time when I
was a kid we could cross-country ski
pretty much everywhere but there's not a
hell of a lot of snow and it's not as
you can see sticking all that well
unfortunately so this is our view from
our one window in our apartment it's
kind of a nice early in morning and
evening as the Sun is rising and setting
and we get the buildings behind us so I
figured I would just chat a little bit
well everybody piles in it's still a
minute before we're officially supposed
to begin and I think everything is set
up properly with the live control room
and all of that business
if not then then I'm not able to here we
go December pop-up there we go so let's
see how how this works should be seeing
huh good I see somebody live chatting in
already
hello FA not mispronouncing your name
all right so now I'm gonna actually sit
down because there's no way I'm holding
that laptop in my arms all day long
today
the philosophy pop up we're going to
talk about sort of a holiday-themed
philosophy in general and what it has to
tell us about festivals and holidays so
there's a lot of room for discussion I
think a lot of interesting topics I had
in mind to talk about and I'm just going
to touch on them you know people can
always ask me questions and we can go
into more detail about this
was gonna talk about play-doh maybe
touch on Aristotle talked about Seneca
the stoic also talked about Xenophon a
little bit and then we'll move out of
the Classical period and talk about more
modern thinkers in part for his talk
about you know what's going on in birth
tragedy and then there's a few thinkers
that I was bringing up that you might
not be all that familiar with and it
looks like I only brought down one of
the books one is Mikhail Bakhtin
some of you may be familiar with this
book where he he sort of lays out his
theory of the festival and then I wanted
to talk about Johan Huizinga the
theorist of play and Marquis le odd the
great philosopher of religion and what
he had to say about about all that sort
of stuff so for viewers at this point in
time so that that's pretty cool I better
check to see whether people are signing
in and saying I'm first time welcome to
everybody to the Hangout so let me start
by talking about Plato and when we think
about philosophy and festivals at least
for me the first thing that comes to
mind is his dialogue the symposium which
I described is a weird drinking party
where instead of drinking which they do
to some extent they decide to put it off
and start talking with each other about
about love and it's it's a really
interesting dialogue in part because
most of the people there are in fact
related to each other in some sort of
erotic fashion or another and they each
give this great speech and it's a
beautiful piece of literature it's one
of the finest and in Western philosophy
and literature but there's there's not a
lot of discussion of actual merrymaking
there's a lot of joking back and forth
some of which is easier to get in the
Greek than in the English translations
and then finally Alcibiades comes in at
the end totally drunk and turns it into
a real party
which point he gives a speech of things
start to break down and it's a party
that goes all the way until the morning
where there's just three people left
arguing with each other Socrates and the
representatives of tragedy and comedy
you know debating about whether the same
person could in fact be a comedian or a
tragedy and and then you know the guy
who's narrating it wakes up he's past
hug before that so it's quite a party
and then everything continues and I
think one of the things that I wanted to
bring up
I talked about this at the Culinary
Institute of America at one of their
conferences that was held outdoors a
number of years ago and we actually did
do some drinking of some I forget
exactly what it was brewed but they
brought in some stuff and my talk was
called why did we quit drinking and it
was about symposia and you know this is
a very common way of engaging with each
other in the ancient world we'd have
these drinking parties there primarily
for the upper and middle classes and we
had a lot of representatives of that in
literature so one that I wanted to bring
up Xenophon he actually has a symposium
as well and in their symposium they do
drink and they don't send away the
entertainers and Socrates actually gets
into an argument with one of the people
who's in charge of the entertainment so
it's quite an interesting piece there's
a lot of great discussion going on in
that and you might want to take a look
at that but one of the other things I
want to bring up is we know from
Diogenes layer taste and from Plutarch
that many other people wrote symposia in
the ancient world including Epicurus now
wouldn't it be interesting to have
Epicurus as symposium and be able to see
what what he's talking about in there
and then Plutarch himself wrote this
this thing that's usually translated as
the symposium
it's what else can we say about it it's
got all these sub discussions where he's
bringing up other people and what they
had to think about different things and
and it goes on for quite a ways so that
might be worth checking out but we know
that there's there's probably many more
literary symposia that we've lost over
the course of time than we actually do
possess so that's that's something that
that's quite interesting let me take a
question quick before I jump into
anything else this is from Pierre I
think I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing
this right what topics does Socrates
cover in Plato's symposium by the way
you sure look like Lebowski yeah this is
my this is my the dude sweater that my
wife got me for Christmas last year I
said I was gonna shoot some videos where
I was you know sort of taking on the
persona of the dude and the reason they
actually got it for me was precisely
because in some of my older videos maybe
I'll do this right now in some of my
older videos where I have my hair down
because my hair is actually quite long
people would remark on them you know
looks like the dude is teaching
philosophy now my hair is actually quite
a bit longer than then Jeff Bridges
character was in that but you know I I
do get any like if I could go bowling
especially I've got some pictures of me
going bowling
actually duckpin bowling which is the
little bowling things in this this
letter you can see them on my Facebook
page and I think on my Google+ people
would say well the dude is here but of
course it's a dude with with glasses who
has you know a good bit of gray hair has
his beard is turning white so so an
agent dude okay so back what do they
talk about it in Plato's symposium it's
a great great question it's about love
and so everybody is supposed to give a
speech about love and it's an amazing
dialogue in part because Plato who is
able to imitate all their genres he's
able to make a medical doctor talk like
a physicist you know a physical you know
you say somebody who's obsessed with the
physics of the time he's able to make
their Aristophanes do a comedic thing
Agathon talks like a writer it's really
quite amazing and each of them gives a
speech that builds
to a climax and then there's a day
Newmont when I like I said Alcibiades
who was in love with Socrates comes in
and and stirs things up Bob Knight asks
was Socrates real
yeah Socrates was real he was an actual
historical person that's it's
interesting there there are these people
who have theories and this not only
applies to Socrates and Jesus but
there's even discussion about like it
was there a historical Buddha was there
a historical Confucius was you know it
goes throughout the thing there's always
somebody who's a skeptic it was like
well the only evidence we have is this
this text where somebody talked about it
yeah that's the evidence that's the way
it is for pretty much everybody who
lived in ancient times and there's you
know the historians don't least
historians in the mainstream don't think
that there's any good reason to doubt
that Socrates or Confucius or Jesus or
the Buddha or pick whoever you like
existed and you know the people who do
think no no they you know we don't have
evidence for it there really I'm on the
fringe but sometimes they present
themselves as if they're in the
mainstream let me take a few other
things so yeah the dude are you gonna
attend the annual dudas convention next
year I don't know where it is so I
suppose that I could if it's nearby I
know they had it Milwaukee or there's
some sort of Milwaukee Lebowski Fest
every year and I suppose I should go to
it but it's probably in the summer and
this might be a little bit hot to wear
so I'd have to do something like I guess
where the bathrobe or something along
those lights I got a I can watch the
movie for quite some time so so I'll
have to do some research about that all
right so let me come back to what I
wanted to talk about so symposia are
these these you know drinking parties
and we we changed the meaning of the
term somewhere along the line so that
they became these very staid academic
affairs where nobody's doing any
drinking and everybody shuts up so the
people up on the stage can
chitter-chatter about whatever
it happens to be world peace or you know
this kind of food product or you know I
don't know there's probably a whole
bunch of symposia I'm very trivial
things Aristotle makes fun of people for
writing pan gyrus about salt I'm sure
there's somebody who's had a symposium
on deodorants something along those
lines
so with symposia where originally were
you know these these parties where
people would get together and they they
weren't always necessarily friends with
each other some of them might actually
be rivals but they would drink and they
would have a good time and there were
some entertainment and if they wanted to
chat about something important they
could if they just wanted to you know
eat good food and enjoy them so so what
was it like it's like a dinner party but
think about a dinner party you know a
lot of dinner parties are kind of stuffy
Affairs there's all this protocol
involved in it think about a fun dinner
party with your friends with plenty of
good liquor and you know beer I'm into
beer myself and you know you get to talk
about stuff at your leisure that's what
what a symposium was like and I think
that that's that's something important
for doing not just philosophy but but
really anything that involves creativity
and also interpretation is there these
personal interactions turn out to be so
important I've had so many great ideas
well I don't call them great I've had so
many ideas that I've gotten in in
conversations with people very often not
at the actual you know official
symposium but in the reception
afterwards chatting over some beers and
or you know going out for a meal or or
something like that and I think that
this is an important component to to
philosophy
not everybody's philosophy granted but
but to quite a few people so that leads
into one of the other topics and okay
I'm going to
let's see here
let me answer a few other things
off-topic thoughts on fest lots of
festivity due to the loss of a religious
sentiment and Joseph peepers work
related to it I mean read peepers work
related to it but it might be connected
to what we'll talk about a little bit
later on in here and Yeji writes I wish
I could hold the symposium sounds fun
yeah it was one of those things that in
ancient times you generally had to have
some resources to be able to do but we
can do it on a smaller scale just
getting together with a few friends and
you know having something it doesn't
necessarily have to be in toxicants we
could always do it over tea or coffee
but there has to be I think an element
of play or enjoyment or fun involved in
it so let me talk about one of the other
people I wanted to bring up the Stoics
you know when we think of the Stoics we
don't think of people necessarily having
a good time now if you went to stomach
on then you probably you know and you
went to the reception you probably saw
some people actually enjoying themselves
and interestingly all of the people on
the modern stoicism team are people who
I would say unqualifiedly
know how to have a good time with other
people so you know are they diverging
from it
sonica has this great letter where he's
talking about festivals and he talks
about the Saturnalia
this is particularly you know apt
because we're going here like in the
United States until the holiday season
as we call it right and the reason why
we say the holiday season is so
everybody can be included because we've
got you know Hanukkah we've got
Christmas sometimes we get other things
you know that are cyclical winding up at
the same time we have Kwanzaa then we
have the New Year's which was always
kind of a bit of a Bacchanalia and you
know the Saturnalia was it was the day
that eventually became Christmas and it
was a time for excess it was a time for
craziness it was a time to let loose
you know and so Seneca says it's
December and everybody's sweating why
are they sweated because you know but
the time for this festival is here and
then he considers something he says you
know I think a lot of people think that
you should avoid this as a stoic right
you should you should try to get away
from any sort of merrymaking because
that's gonna be tempting and you will
lose your self-control and you will not
be you know dignified and all that he
says well you could go that way but on
the other hand if you can go to the
party and knock it you know so drunk
that you're falling down and throwing up
over yourself and making passes at
people and hooking up with random
strangers then that actually probably
shows more self-control than just saying
oh I'm not going to do this at all so
you know you could say Seneca is saying
don't be a party pooper
just partake in parties moderately don't
you know don't allow yourself to be just
drawn in and do all the crazy stuff
Epictetus says something can't be
similar its main effect I wrote a piece
for stoicism today last year about about
that sort of thing and I might revisit
it again this coming year the you know
epictetus says you know when when
there's a festival and you see the
children clapping their hands and doing
all the stuff don't get down on em don't
say oh that's for you know juvenile
people let them do what they're gonna do
and as a matter of fact if they come up
to you and they want you to clap your
hands to them go go ahead and do that
because it's really a small gesture you
don't have to like you know get so
involved in it and I think that's really
great advice if you're trying to
practice some sort of intentional
philosophically based lifestyle no of
course if you're an alcoholic maybe
don't have a drink right if you know
that you have problems with things maybe
you do need to avoid that sort of thing
for the time being right but in general
if you're trying to improve your life
that doesn't mean that you have to strip
away every single possible pleasure
especially at a time where that's
probably gonna be a downer for for other
people I mean unless you've got the kind
of friends who are you know constantly
yelling let's do shots you know and they
can't even have a good time
you're doing shots with them you're
probably not gonna hurt anybody by just
drinking a moderate amount and and
smiling and enjoying it and then leaving
the party when you want to leave it I
think that's that's some pretty good
advice let me come back to the the the
comments all right so yeah
Roberto writes we used to do it from
time to time at a coffee shop during the
university yeah you know it when I was a
graduate student one of the things that
we used to do pretty regularly with some
of the professors the younger professors
was they would some of them would say
let's go to this coffee shop which was
not a very long walk from from our
campus and just you know have some
coffees and sit around and chat and then
some some of the others like to go to
bars and we'd have some beers and
continue the conversation afterwards I
thought that was great I loved doing
that sort of thing as a matter of fact
last year one of the things that they
did for snowicon' last year that I
thought was pretty cool in the idea
didn't quite work out the way they
wanted was to have some of the speakers
and I did this make themselves available
to go out and have dinner afterwards
with some of the some of the the you
know participants who signed up for it
it was like a fundraising thing that we
were doing it didn't work out that well
in part because it ended up being so
noisy that it was hard to have a good
conversation but I think that you know
that sort of thing would really make a
lot of sense to do in other ways all
right so ty writes I have a friend who
took stoicism to me and it is his duty
to tell the truth in such a degree that
he tells people rather hurtful things
and then he says it is that person's
fault if they get hurt so their that
that person's doing stoicism wrong
that's all there is stuff to say about
that
I mean if epictetus were around and he
rated epictetus epictetus would sort of
lay into him and you know explain to him
exactly how off-base he was but there
there's quite a few people like that
yeah I mean oh the cure for that I think
is is learning more stoicism which means
you know actually seeing what what the
Stoics wrote about about these sorts of
matters peer writes one wonders what
Hagel would have to say about festivals
and collective consciousness if anything
at all
and then also raised to animals
celebrate any festival I don't know
about animals celebrating festivals but
we you know animals sure do like to play
with each other and I think that's a key
component you know like when we take our
dogs we've got two dogs laying around
here you heard one of them drinking
water earlier probably they're old so
they don't go to the dog park very very
frequently anymore because they're
arthritic and they can't and they try to
do too much they try to run with the
other dogs and it's not good for them
but when they were younger and we take
him to the dog park that's like a
holiday for them all right I get to
smell everybody run around and do things
and so I don't know if that's a festival
or not but could be you know and I don't
know do birds have festivals like when
they're getting together you know
elephants elephants actually seems to
take stock of each other's deaths which
I guess would throw Heidegger for a bit
of a loop and I think other animals do
as well you know not all of our
festivals are necessarily celebratory
festivals if you think about funerals
and and you know my grave cleaning
festivals like you know Ching Ming and
in a traditional Chinese stuff I think
those are quite important as well now
does take will have anything to say
about festivals I mean he actually uses
the the festival in the preface to the
the phenomenology where like everybody's
you know this bacchanal e and things so
of course he was aware of that and Hegel
seemed to be a guy who had a good time
from time to time by the way so was Khan
Kant was really into dinner parties and
you know I haven't looked at Hegel's
aesthetics but I'm willing to bet that
there's something in there
now Darrin writes about something that I
don't really know about could you
quickly give your opinion on found here
int ism I that's not even a word that
I'd know so I don't have any opinion at
it I'm not sure what it is so if you
want to write something about that maybe
what what the idea is I'll take a look
at that pair following up on that my
theory as they play to digest extra food
energy I don't think that there is a
single functional explanation for play
and I don't think we need one I think I
think that it's it's an element of you
know life once it gets to a certain
level that it engages in something like
like play for for enjoyment I mean
there's also functional things like when
cats are wrestling with each other you
know they're learning how to fight and
how to take down animals all of that
sort of stuff but I don't know that we
need it ty writes I normally miss these
opportunities to say how much I
appreciate the knowledge you share so
thank you so much I'll be returning to
your videos for years to come that's
very nice for you too to say I'm glad
and I'm gonna keep on producing the
videos I I can't imagine you know a time
when I'm going to stop not not just
because I actually enjoyed doing it but
because it seems to me that there's so
much that still hasn't been done in
YouTube for you know centered in the
text discussions of of things I mean you
can find lots of five minutes sort of
glitzy videos on this or that thing but
they often don't have a lot of content
unfortunately and sometimes very
actually wrong
and those are those do tend to get a lot
of views but I think and I try to get my
colleagues into shooting videos it's an
incredibly difficult sell to try to get
anybody to post anything online if their
their academics unfortunately daniel has
a very nice comment - I love your
channel keep up the good work
I certainly will so there's a little bit
of a lull let me come back then to some
of the stuff that I
and wanted to discuss I'd mentioned the
Stoics and I also said I was going to
talk a little bit about Nietzsche you
know if you if you think about the birth
of tragedy right it's about these
festivals and what's taking place in
Greece and we usually in terms of the
DNS see act versus Apollonian associate
festivals with the the DNS yet this
letting loose this you know losing
ourself in in the crowd in an
intoxication and there is something to
that but but I think the Apollonian is
also very important to keep in mind for
Nietzsche you really get the most
mileage out of both DNS and Apollonian
when they're working together and then
the bad guy is actually the Socratic the
one who's rationalist the one who thinks
everything can be explained and you
might say in some respects you know the
Plato's symposium is a less Socratic
dialogue then say the faith no or in in
Nietzsche's sense right there's more
there's more respect given to the power
of a dose of you know desire drive you
know it's true it's being sublimated to
this higher thing and ultimate meaning
to the form of beauty or the form of the
good but there's this this understanding
that you know we don't we have to have
this engagement in in our real life and
with with other people tonisha you know
I think it's an important person to
bring up in this light that the birth of
tragedy is kind of interesting but also
if you think about what's going on in
the genealogy of morals and talking
about punishment and how cruelty
nietzsche theny she has this theory that
that societies that are able to
countenance a certain amount of what
what appears to be just sort of want and
cruelty are also in a certain respect
freer societies all sorts of what with
the you might say the original of human
existence is and that there's there's
there's some joy involved obviously not
joy for the person who's suffering but
the
there's more what he calls cheerfulness
involved and he thinks that this is
something that got lost in the shuffle
particularly through Christianity and
you might say the sublimation of various
religious activities into to that
alright let's see what we got here
coming up
Nate writes I am reviewing for a final
about stoicism epicureanism and
skepticism could you perhaps briefly
summarize the core tenets of each
philosophy so that's not really about
festivals and holidays or anything like
that and I will give it a very quick
shot and then if you want to do a follow
up with me that's the sort of thing
you'd booked a tutorial session for
rather than try to you know with with
final exam on this so stoicism live in
accordance with nature and that means a
fully developed human nature
Epicureanism pleasure and pain are the
only good and evil everything's
evaluated in terms of that skepticism
well we don't really know about anything
and to every argument in equal argument
can be opposed so that's not gonna get
you through a final exam though that's
not quite enough Aaron writes doctors
family really love your channel
greetings from Honduras well thanks glad
that you do Kyle some have commented
that one of the largest gatherings of
modern stomachs could be on wizard
Cheyenne a site for male celibates are
you aware of this community no I'm
barely aware of any of the chants my
briefest brush with that was was digging
a little bit around Fortran because I'd
been turned into a meme on there I don't
know anything about wizard Shan and I
think that you know couldn't be a stoic
whether you're celibate or married or
you know you know whatever you know
there's all sorts of possibilities with
that so I don't I don't think it's
necessarily associated with with
celibacy maybe the the idea of having an
intentional life so but unless I
actually like went on and checked it out
I would not automatically a
that to the stoicism and in particular
get particularly given that many people
like take one bit of stoicism then say
I'm a stoic you know rather than looking
at the other stuff which tends to go
against what they're doing so you know I
don't know I can't really say anything
about it
Andrew Hooper are we ever going to hear
your banjo Sabbath covers so I don't
actually have any Black Sabbath covers
that I do on my banjo but I I do have
some other things in metal anyway I do a
lot I do a good bit of scorpions and
some Judas Priest some Motorhead
Oh some tank some you have fall I don't
actually I don't think I have any
Sabbath stuff but I've done I mean I
played around with it before but usually
it were white that requires me to find
the guitar chords for it right
so are we ever going to hear my banjo
stuff yeah I got to practice before I I
would do that but but maybe I'll maybe
I'll get it out at the end of this we'll
see what's my opinion on Richard Rorty
well you got Rick our drordy that would
be a better day Richard Rorty it's kind
of a cool name I think he was he was big
stuff when I was in graduate school I
never found him very interesting because
he was basically saying you know look
Heidegger and Dewey and Vidkun Stein are
all more or less doing the same thing
and I mean we were doing that as
graduate students but I just wasn't
particularly impressed and he was being
positioned as sort of the end of the you
know pragmatist lineage and I was like
well that's that's an example for why I
don't have to think too much about them
care rights so here we go this is a
little bit skipped down a little bit
Daniel writes and reading either/or by
sir and Kierkegaard
I was wondering what your take on it
take on him is in regards to Hegel's
philosophy since I'm as far as far as
I'm aware he disagreed with a lot of
Hegel's views yeah he disagreed with
quite a few of Hegel's views he knew his
Hegel the disagreement is often less
pronounced than a lot of summaries make
it out to be
he's more actually attacking the
galleons of his time than Hegel himself
but using Hegel is kind of a foil so you
know for example he'll criticize Handel
for saying that faith is what you start
with and then you move into you know a
fuller understanding of the religious
object but in many respects you know I
think it's worth if you think about
Kierkegaard's like three you know stages
right you've got the the aesthetic stage
then the ethical stage then the
religious stage and the the people who
really represent the theorizing of the
ethical stage the most are Socrates and
Hegel and the ethical isn't something
bad it's just there's more than then
what can be fit within it and so it's
not like Hegel and some how bad or awful
he's be sure as hell is better than a
lot of other philosophers as far as
height as far as Kierkegaard is
concerned I will said Heidegger but
Heidegger actually thought very highly
of Hegel - but he's missing something
there's there's something that went
wrong in in the process and so you know
it's always worth remembering that that
you know Kierkegaard himself is a
dialectical thinker and he's not aiming
at some sort of higher synthesis that
encompasses everything but the ethical
isn't that isn't something bad it's
actually you know very important in our
lives
block somebody who wrote some
alright think twice how would you
connect your last assumption about
Nietzsche with his idea of ressentiment
well I'm not making any assumptions each
of those are there in the text and the
notion of his anthems anthem for those
we don't know you can find a really
great discussion of this in the
genealogy but it winds up being
discussed in other places where xanthoma
comes about because people are unable to
to you know express their effects of
desire for revenge and they have to shut
it down or or you know tell themselves
stories about why why they shouldn't do
that and that you know tends to lead to
not just for that person but also for a
culture a situation in which there
they're not going to be able to be
spontaneous they're gonna be trying to
you know pull everything down these are
gonna be people who are not good good
partiers they're not could be fun to
have around and they're gonna be
detracting from from things so a culture
that's filled with Roseanne tamam is is
going to be a culture that doesn't
really know how to have a lot of fun
that's what I would say Perry writes
Nietzsche says knowledge kills action
and action requires the veils of
illusion is knowledge then the veil of
illusion or action which is not an
illusion must be free from knowledge as
this abyss he's only saying that about
one thing he's not saying that that this
applies to every single circumstance
that's coming from the the genealogy and
you know there's different kinds of
knowledge so not all knowledge
automatically results on us not beholden
to anything and really if you think
about you know what's going this is part
of what I talked about at my seminars
and my webinar last month talking about
Nietzsche he talked about the problem of
life in the ji in the birth of tragedy
later on he'll talk about an abyss right
but the problem of life is realizing
that life doesn't have any
meaning to it and it may in fact induce
in us a sense of nausea he uses the term
there in that work
that's like staring into the abyss and
the later stuff to heal right it's for
me the greatest thing about stoicism was
helping me understand what is in my
control and what is out of my control
and thus help me deal with my anger yeah
that's actually what led me into paid
more attention to stoicism myself if you
know my biography which I talked about
different places here and there so if
you don't know it but I think a lot of
you heard me in other places I got into
studying stoicism seriously because I
was doing a lot of work anger and
looking at philosophical resources you
know in Aristotle and Plato also in
Plutarch you know as platonic thinker
and Christian thought and then in the
Stoics and I found a lot of really cool
stuff there and that that's probably
what helped me take the Stoics more
seriously because I had studied them
before but I hadn't really taken them
that that seriously
you know if to go back to the theme of
like festivals and holidays right and be
really helpful that distinction between
what's in my control and what's not in
my control you can plan a party and
nobody can show up you know sometimes I
do these online events and it's like I
picked the wrong time and like you know
five or six people show up sometimes a
hundred people show up you know
sometimes more you don't you can set
things up in such a way that it looks
like you know things should come
together well but you don't have any
control over that there's so many
outside factors like sometimes we would
do these these events here in town at
libraries and you know we do them like
on a Thursday night attended and then
you know like it would happen to fall on
the one night that it's a Thursday night
Packer game well we could bet hardly
anybody's going to show up right that's
that's what happens you can introduce
you can like make a dinner party and
have all these people you think are cool
people get together and you just
didn't realize that these other two know
each other and have a personality
conflict going back to their high school
days or something like that you know
that's not on you you know that's just
the way things pan out sometimes so I
think that's that's Aaron rights maybe a
systemic approach of Kierkegaard's ideas
through his criticism towards Hegel I'm
sure that's done yeah somewhere in the
secondary literature
I'm not a big secondary literature
person in part because I work on so many
different figures that I would never
have the time to read much of the
secondary lit and get to spend time with
the primary text I don't really even get
enough time with them retro gamer it
brings up the sweater again was at Jeff
Bridges character the dude which
furnished your selection of the sweater
II where you are the dude my wife want
me in the sweater for Christmas last
year and she bought it for me because I
had so many comments on my YouTube
things when I had my hair down like when
I was teaching at MERIS that oh this is
the dude teaching philosophy when I put
my hair up unfortunately and because I'm
you know kind of a fat guy I would
instead get especially if I wore a suit
oh is Penn from Penn & Teller teaching
philosophy so let's see what we got here
jumping around a little bit in the thing
see Chris how does Heidegger's view of
existentialism differ from Tsar's well
I'll just give a really short answer to
that
Heidegger got rid of the term
existentialist when he found out what so
hard he thought it was and he wasn't the
only one Gabrielle Marcel did the same
thing they were willing to like leave it
to him
Heidegger thinks that Sartre is wrong
and thinking that existentialism or an
existentialist analysis should be a
humanist perspective and so the source
you want to look at for that is the
letter on humanism
all right so Darrin has a follow-up
found here int ISM is the catification
of coherent ISM and found
journalism in epistemology do you think
the idea of joining the two concepts
together is possible to do I don't know
whenever people are using isms and stuff
like that in you know philosophy it's
usually coming out of some discussions
an analytic philosophy they usually tend
to be extremely abstract and requires
some you know reading of a literature
that I haven't read I don't know what
what what's men I know what
foundationalism typically means although
it means a bunch of different things
depending on what discourse you're I'm
not sure what coherent ism means and so
whether they could be combined and I'm
really not the guy to tell you
subconscious rights can you please name
some of the philosophical works in
modern analytic philosophy that you've
found intellectually stimulating so I
don't read a lot of modern analytic
stuff meaning stuff from like the 70s on
in part because I just simply don't have
the time you know the the David Lewis in
his world
you know many-worlds semantics was kind
of big when I was in graduate school and
I I dug around a bit in that thought it
was a you know kind of interesting but I
thought that authors are doing far more
interesting stuff with that that the
philosophers were I like you know I like
some of the older analytic stuff I loved
reading John wisdom but he's kind of a
interesting fellow he doesn't fit the
mold of a typical analytic philosophy
he's willing to read across until you
know Freud and Sartre and try to make
sense of that sort of stuff I guess you
could say that that you know I mean a
certain point he quit being an analytic
philosopher but I love Alistair
MacIntyre stuff and I find his early
stuff very interesting Rose of course
[Music]
who else
you know I like I like reading around in
the older stuff when they were just kind
of figuring out that the lodge business
project was not going to work they can
shine is somebody who I I go back to and
I enjoy reading you know I talked about
my Vidkun Stein phase when I was really
quite quite enamored of him I don't you
know nobody really comes to mind in
contemporary analytic stuff where I'm
like wow this is really amazing I need
to read this stuff and respond to it so
you know in part because you know I was
just saying so foundationalism can mean
a number of different things one of the
problems with the current analytic
philosophy this is what I'm getting from
friends who are analytic philosophers is
that you have all these discourses and
they love to coin new terminology and it
means one thing in epistemology and
another thing in thing in philosophy of
language and so you got to do so much
digging it's basically like a new form
of scholasticism you know as Hobbes said
jangling with words rather than
attending to the things themselves and I
find it very unproductive it's just you
know I've only got so many hours per day
so so I'm not going to spend a lot of
time on it um read and writes what do
you think about postmodern theology and
it's interesting you mentioned Allen sir
in that because because he is like
really really but unless I'm mistaken
he's really old I read a little death of
God theology stuff interesting but you
know not that interesting being made
about what's modern it's sort of like
reading Baldwin you know you read stuff
like well because we can flip the light
switch on and off everything's changed
you're like all of these like you know
the old stuff is all dead you know
pronouncements they're all forgotten and
the old stuff still sticks around Caputo
I never took Caputo very seriously maybe
I should have I don't know I've seen him
talk at conferences I've read some of
his stuff just never really got into it
you know and I think that the word
postmodern one of those terms that
meanings of it are all over the man you
know all you got to do is like read
Jameson's work on it where he's
identifying four different very clear
senses of it and so I never use that
that word very much oh here's a good one
from Daniel is it morally justified to
tell children Santa Claus exists in
order to influence them into behaving
more appropriately if that's the only
justification for telling them that that
Santa Claus exists I'd say no there's
other ways of getting people to behave
more appropriately but then again I you
know I told my kids Santa Claus does
exist it exists in several different
ways
I mean he's okay so if you actually do
believe that you know people it'll
continue on after after their death
which which I do there's a whole
different whole you know can of worms to
get into and and you know you think that
there is a st. Nicholas he does exist
he's not the guy wearing the red suits
so there's a different thing right there
but then you can tell an interesting
story about how the people who are you
know wearing the red suits are in some
way you know participating in the
narrative about say necklace and
obviously you don't you don't you know
try to lay this on a three-year-old or
five-year-old or something like that but
it's not as if it's just pure
fabrication if we're coming at it from a
certain aspect and you know if you think
about what are we supposed to be doing
emulating that that guy who was a pretty
good guy in many respects by the way
I'll mention that one of the people who
I work on st. handsome he's got a prayer
to st. Nicholas and why why would he
have a prayer to st. Nicholas because
st. Nicholas was not known for presence
there anything like that back in the
Middle Ages he was viewed as a very
important model in an intercessor it's
kind of interesting to take a look at
but yeah if it if it's just
trying to police their behavior I don't
think it's a good great lecture on
Heidegger's analysis of the cave in
juxtaposition with your appraisal of
both I'm glad you liked it I'll be
shooting three more videos three more
core concept videos on that piece
the guy who commissioned it actually got
quite a bargain because I originally
thought I could do the thing in just one
video and then realized I needed to do
for follow-up do you think there's a
relation between Plato's forms and the
furnishing of in individual instincts in
an anti intelligible transition a
relationship between Plato's forms and
individual instincts I don't know what
that would possibly be so say what that
would would wind up being we're getting
a lot of I had to take a minute to block
another porn bot it's kind of funny I
guess they saw a Holiday Festival and
they thought we're looking for a
different kind of festival all right
sage master some say about life that
you're inside of it so everything you
can find can only be a piece of it since
it is the lens through which you view
the world so it is bigger than meaning
just got here
okay that makes sense I mean here's
here's a sort of application of that
that comes up like people are always
like what text so I have to read I don't
want to waste my time on you know the
wrong texts and philosophy and I don't
want to get the wrong ideas I got it you
know and you know whoa slow down to
begin with nobody can read all the texts
that are available and you probably
can't even work your way through all the
essential texts in the history of
philosophy because I can't write and I
and I do this full-time but I've been
doing it for now it's not so important
that you you know try to have the right
perspective and then you know everything
will fall into place we are in process
we are you know as
you know the French would say you know
we're already on the voyage thinking
about Maurice blown-down I wrote my
dissertation on it don't read very often
anywhere I said you know we're already
embarked doesn't mean that we can't get
some sort of sense of it doesn't mean
that some people don't have better
conceptions of life than others but yeah
do we ever have like a total got
everything totally figured out kind of
you I don't think so
retro gamer rights way a lot of stuff
here I'm gonna scroll up a bit forms
becoming shadow representation and
instinctual perhaps on earth by emotion
now I think I understand what you're
talking about so so really what you're
asking about is how does what we call
the Platonic doctrine of recollection
work right is there is there something
that's you know not purely intellectual
about it but but effective and I think
the answer for Plato is yes there
actually is I don't know that I would
say in terms of instincts hardwiring you
know but certainly there is an effective
response many talks but that's very
clearly in dialogue after dialogue after
dialogue Pepa writes dr. Sandler once
you take on the view that stoicism is a
watered down version of cynicism I
believe the following statement is
attributed to epictetus if you can't be
a cynic at least be a stoic I don't
recall seeing that and I've read
Epictetus many times
Epictetus has a great chapter a fashion
where he says this is not for 99% of you
or for me by the way but here's what to
expect if you're going to be a cynic and
interestingly we know we learn more
about the cynics chapter than we do from
any existing cynic literature so we
don't really have much to go on it would
be you know just from a scholarly
perspective to say stoicism is a
watered-down version of cynicism
that would be a very speculative stance
to take because we don't we don't
actually have the documents to support
that you know I don't see it as that I
see those as two different paths and I
think that you know the Stoics were
right to the cynics you know may have
gone too far with with some things I
also think that comic portrayal of the
cynics anaesthetics clearly there were
plenty of people talking to talk about
being cynics but really just being jerks
they're gonna have a stoicism as well
but yeah all right Elijah asks is it
possible to synchronize a total belief
in God or the total acceptance of
science depends on what you believe what
you mean by belief in God and science
there so you know those mean multiple
things again all right I'm gonna skip
down a little bit
Aleksei writes what does stoicism saying
idealism or does that differ between
philosophers I'd have to know what
idealism means their idealism is one of
those terms that means a lot of
different things as well here's a good
one Stanislav right I'm a student
first-year philosophy do you have any
advice for studying things I need to
keep an eye out for take my time with it
anything at all concerning my academia
yeah I mean remember that every
philosophical text if it's if it's a
classic the more times you read it the
more the more you're gonna find in it
and it's okay to forget things because
you can always just go back to the text
unless you lose the book and we're
fortunate now that we live in an age
where books are easy to get and
oftentimes they're available in PDF form
online faith or in other forms so you
don't have to really like you know sweat
that so much you know I'd say that as a
beginning Institute and there's there's
a lot of it you know it really depends
on a person's temperament and how
they're approaching philosophically I
would say that it
better to try to find a few thinkers who
you get a lot out of and you lot you'll
learn that by it by you know experience
and and spend time with them keep going
back to their works see if you can find
other people that are interested in them
as well if you're lucky enough to be
able to find a class that's great a lot
of the thing here is that we'd like to
study you know we often have difficulty
finding classes on them and then
sometimes the class might be talking by
somebody who doesn't really like the
thinker because the way academics work
but definitely here's what here's one
other thing is a bit of negative advice
whatever the people in in philosophy
tell you is the stuff that you have to
learn because that's the most important
you know and and everybody's studying
this and everything before it was crap
and and you know everybody has to go
through this whether it be something an
analytic philosophy or continental
philosophy or if you had certain
Catholic institutions that you must read
st. Thomas because he has the right
words on everything full of crap and you
know you can look at this historically
and see people making those sorts of
assertions over and over over again and
it never turns out to be that way you
know we've been told a million times now
metaphysics is dead you know or this
this is done and stuff that's really
cool back
you're never gonna keep Plato down you
can punch him down as many times as you
like he's gonna keep on coming back
same thing with Aristotle same thing
with the Stoics you know and and you
know we may reinterpret it in different
ways but you know and we want to think
about like well who's worth studying now
you know some some of the people that
that wrote stuff in the 20th century
we're gonna keep reading them long after
I'm dead and if those of you were
younger than me after you're dead
but most of them are not you know most
of them are gonna be the equivalent of
Herbert Spencer where you know he's
there's books you can you can read them
nobody cracks them open anymore you know
so alright ah my question is what would
the Stoics say about bullying how would
they deal with it what
esra Seneca or Cicero approach such a
topic so I've written about this in my
blog or XS T and O n TK I've actually
addressed this this issue a couple of
different times you know obviously don't
believe that's probably not what you're
asking about you but you know one of the
key issues is should you should you you
know just say oh I'm a stoic so I'm not
gonna let it get to me well unless
you're the sage it probably is gonna get
to you so you may need to do something
about and bullying is unjust and the
Stoics say that we're supposed to try to
attain justice so there may be cases
where you would actually intervene and
if you're seeing somebody who's
vulnerable who's not a stoic getting
bullied and you have the the resources
to actually intervene you wouldn't want
to do that so all right okay
here's a great good one from Kyle in
spectator sports a festivity and as it's
something that ancient Stoics look down
upon yeah I think for the most part they
they tended to look down upon spectator
sports which which I mean some of them
you know like the gladiatorial combats
right or chariot racing right now epic
Tina says a lot of metaphors drawn from
athletic training and the Olympics so
clearly they didn't think that all all
spectator sports were were bad I mean
the notion that like sports should
become what we're fascinated with that
would you know that would be a problem
for the Stoics and and not just the
Stoics I mean you know think about
Augustine and his talking about in you
know the confessions the the fascination
that people had with gladiatorial
combats or or with other things going on
there's a tendency for people who get
really involved in sports to make that
their world by the way if you ever want
to see a movie that illustrates the
it's readiness and despair underlying
that sort of attitude watch the movie
Buffalo I think it's Buffalo 66 with
Vincent Gallo watch the depiction of his
mom who's obsessed with with you know
the Buffalo Bills and their comeback
chances and all of that itself I you
know I'm a Packers fan I'm actually also
a Bears fan believe it or not to which
were a lot of people is an anthem of a
family in Chicago so I kind of grew up
liking both both of them are doing
terrible this year and you know that
with adopting sort of philosophical
attitude
I enjoy the games and I don't let myself
get too anxious about what the score is
and you know if somebody does a good
play on the other side I enjoy that but
I see a lot of people who get very very
very wrapped up in that and it becomes
almost like a surrogate family religion
you know friendship so that that can be
kind of an issue for for people
we're okay retro gamer McIntyre is a
virtue ethicist or some other area and
early work he becomes a virtue ethicist
and for after virtue you know he's
already moving in that direction but he
starts out actually in analytic
philosophy and as a Marxist and then you
know he goes through a lot of
transformations and I can say too
knowing him him personally although not
having correspond with him for quite
some time this is true walks little walk
he's the real deal
Sean rights is the prolegomena a good
introduction account well that's what I
mean Kant thought it was but it's a
tough work you know I don't know that
there is I think of an introduction it
unfortunately is that so the the ideas
that Kant is working with they are to
some degree difficult ideas but the term
nology is so much of what gets in the
way of the average student there are
places where once you actually know what
he's saying and you hear what he's
saying like she can't possibly be in
that candy
and the answer is usually yes because
Conte is uncompromising on certain
things like listen happiness has nothing
to do with morality you know does he
really mean that yep he really means
that so you know is the prolegomena a
good introduction yeah I mean it is it's
certainly a lot easier than reading the
first critique which is really a ed
cracker but it takes some work all right
Shane asks he's wondering if I've run
into Larry Earnhardt's work and what's
my general opinion I don't know
ironheart unfortunately so I can't say
anything bail Hazzard grants have you
read logic comics it's a graphic novel
about Bertrand Russell I actually a
friend of mine sent a copy to me as a
birthday present years back and I have
read it and it is about Russell but if
it was only about Russell I probably
wouldn't want to read it so I'm not a
fan of Russell but it also discusses
Vidkun shine and grew Dale and all these
other things that are going on at the
time which is pretty cool my Frank has
philosophy exam in 15 minutes good luck
Bela Hazzard and I would I would have
loved it here about Santa in that way
when I was little yeah meet me too I
mean I grew up in a family with sort of
can a contradictory stuff about Santa
which was cool because at least then he
kind of slipped through the cracks
because on the one hand Santa Claus was
coming on the twenty you know the night
of the 24th right but because we were
French as my family's french-canadian we
also had you know you know the fete the
sign make a lot right so you put your
boots out and then they get filled up
with like well you know if you're bad
coal which met actually charcoal
briquettes from the grill if your that
was lesser like a warning you better get
your act in gear because there's only a
couple weeks but then you know if you're
good you get like handy
and oranges and stuff and so we thought
it was a little bit strange my jacket
looks so comfortable it is indeed a
comfortable sweater so it's it's a it's
quite nice and I'm glad that I got it
for Christmas and have you ever heard
pop the professor Paula Gottlieb of
uw-madison she's a specialist in
Aristotle no never never met her I don't
know that she's actually been here for
the Aristotle conference that they have
at Marquette I should probably contact
her I mean if you know her go ahead and
put a bug in her ear para rights can you
kindly give a brief introduction on
philosophy of language and its
functional significance of impact no not
really I mean philosophy of language
that's a big field that's actually
something I was very interested in when
I first started Google it's functional
significance and impact I'm not sure
what its functional significance means
its impact very important in the 20th
century
you know analytic philosophy and
continental philosophy both deeply
imbued with with studies of language
retro gamer do you think that when
reading a text you should set out
thinking you have a question to mind
that you're trying or hoping to have an
answer or answers which lead to other
questions it certainly can't hurt but I
don't think it's absolutely necessary
ways of approaching a text so that's
good Marko's thoughts on Aristotle's
magnanimous man the Great's old man is
this the person closest to perfect
morality certainly from an Aristotelian
perspective he is interestingly magna
manatee gets for the Stoics gets brought
under the virtue of courage so you'll
see that discussed and like Cicero
actually uh I think John Sellars
recently did there was either John
Suthers a Kris Gil
recently did a talk about stoicism and
magnanimity that that's something that
later on becomes seen to be a example of
like Augustine talking about how the
ancients regarded great vices as riches
so principled uncertainty I told you
philosophy was going at viral well
that's cool when it happens
Oh Tony
any thoughts on a critical theory of the
projects of the Frankfurt School yeah I
actually I never did much publishing
although I did publish a piece the very
one of the very first pieces I published
was on Adorno and it actually got got
used quite a bit in an online journal
called Minerva good but other people I
seem to have liked it I like reading a
door no I find it extremely difficult to
summarize or to write about him because
his work is like all over the map the
other guys you know I look I do like
some of the stuff that they have say a
lot of it's kind of you know where I'll
read it and I'm like I see where they're
coming from I don't really buy this but
there's some interesting insights there
so yeah let me skip down a bit is
metaphysical knowledge necessary for
mental stability doesn't anxiety
increased if there's a great number of
different possibilities for the way
reality is structured but then you need
education I guess it could help I mean I
don't think everybody needs to study
philosophy and or it's like make their
way through their life and not suffer
from anxiety there's other ways of doing
that I think for some people you know
once you embark on it the only way out
is like going through it so I like to
cartes meditations you know
[Music]
seven rates I would like to know if Carl
Jung has any impact on your views I know
he's inspired by Nietzsche to attempt to
reveal the fire connection with God
no I enjoy reading young but I can't say
he has any really any real impact on my
views so you know but I haven't read him
for a while so you know you never know
down the line perhaps to hear retro
gamer rights would dr. Sandler have the
concept of the classical education
comprising of grammar logic and rhetoric
you mean like would I be endorsing that
I certainly don't think it can hurt I
don't think that it should be like the
only thing that we teach the way that
some classical schools usually run by
conservatives liked it like to do I'm
you know when it comes to really when it
comes to a lot of things I'm quite
they're becoming more and more of a
pluralist these days or I recognize that
different approaches are needed for what
we want to do is be able to provide you
know especially for students we want to
be able to provide them with what it is
that they need at the time which
requires way better teachers I think the
way in which we teach education is is a
real mass buried sources but we also
rely we also need some some real
accountability you know this is this is
really a tough battle especially here in
the United States a lot of things are
kind of rough in a lot of other places
too
Kyle asks is piracy of digital content
theft and is it immoral I don't know it
depends on what we mean by piracy this
is kind of a good question like I think
you know bootleg DVDs and stuff like
that yeah that's theft somebody is like
you know
taking my my videos which has happened
before and then downloading them
basically ripping looks I don't have set
to down though and then putting them on
their channel and getting the meager
money that YouTube wants to give for
that sort of stuff
I guess that's piracy too I don't have a
varied in I have a very dim view of
academic publishing and especially
journal publishing and the money that
they rake in getting authors to to
basically give them material for free
which then they charge huge rates for
and I don't have any problem with
databases that that you know let people
get that because it's sort of like you
know imagine Robin Hood except it's like
the ultra-rich that he's stealing from
so I did you know I guess it depended
appends for me on different things
Robert Duprey writes dr. Sandler keeping
in the theme of holidays and festivity
which philosophers would you consider as
playful or festive at least in the way
they write would you consider Plato to
be one
yeah I would Nietzsche certainly is - I
mean Nietzsche is really fun to read not
only in the English but in the original
German other people are a chore no
matter what you read them in like Hegel
for example you know
Kant every once in a while will have a
funny little quip here and there but
he's kind of mature to read and quite
frankly and Aristotle is not fun to read
Epictetus is actually sometimes without
necessarily meaning to be so the way he
talks to people because he you know he's
got this sort of well when we translate
his freedom of speech or frankness
pareció you know but yeah there's plenty
of other philosophers who are quite good
at that and sometimes you know like when
you go to conferences and you you meet
some of these people they surprise you
at at like how funny they can be so that
that's kind of kind of cool
question here if somebody is gonna be
retiring in a few years and they're
worried about providing for his family
in the future with his meager income how
come stoicism helped it we'll stop
worrying there is actually a penis and
the discourses in book 4 if I remember
right where he doesn't address
retirement he just addresses poverty and
why is it that we fear poverty so much
that might be helpful to take a look at
as the more refined you become isn't the
case that that won't be one becomes more
sensitive to violence of all sorts so
how can the intellectual or the
philosophy become stoic with working
through much anger at injustice well I
mean the anger doesn't help you to be
getting angry at injustice it's possible
like Seneca says to have the same
reaction from reason you know and to use
practical reason to resist injustice
rather than to rely on anger and
actually Seneca treats this in on anger
he says argument that like you know
anger is becoming of the wise person
then the wise person is gonna be pissed
off all the time and that can't possibly
be the case precisely because of what
you're noting which is that they they're
aware of you know how things are are
wrong okay I'm going to grant this aside
I'm going to grad school next year in
University of Toronto any advice well
it's a great school to go to make as
many connections as you can
bridges with people because of stances
that you take at a particular time don't
get sucked into doing work for free for
other people and you know take a wide
range of classes you know get a lot of
different perspectives especially at a
school like that where you have the
opportunity to study with a lot of
different people I would take advantage
of that
two eels meal Epictetus was a slave
early Christians were oppressed I've
heard there's connections between
stoicism and early Christianity can you
talk about whether or not was intended
for the downtrodden so that's kind of
like the take that somebody like
Nietzsche has and really you know people
like Gibbon as well he's enlightenment
historians who actually did pretty bad
history stoicism can arrange as the
gamut
xeno was down on his luck as you know
actually advised the king of Macedon who
was one of the successor kingdoms from
Alexander's time and sent some of his
students there
Cicero not a stoic himself but certainly
interested in stoicism you know Cato
definitely a stoic Marcus Aurelius of
course like I mean this notion that
stoicism was like something that the
downtrodden took refuge in and that's
why they came up with the philosophy
just historically unfounded and I think
the same thing can be said about
Christianity people in the early church
came from all different walks of life
all you gotta do is you know look at the
say the book of Acts and very early on
we see you know plenty of like poor
people but also plenty of intellectuals
in the church so I've never I've never
brought that line in part because it's
it's so oversimplifying usually you know
sort of a remark about history of ideas
usually anytime that somebody's like
selling you a line that this philosophy
just came from this no they've got some
sort of story that they're selling and
some axe to grind it almost never when
we look at the documents turns out to be
true
so oh I saw this what are your thoughts
on Alfred North Whitehead somebody I
wish I had the time to actually read
more and keep meaning to make the time
to read I read process in reality when I
was an undergraduate I thought that it
was amazing
probably only understood about a tenth
of it I would love to be able to go back
and spend the time with it it's you know
it's interesting so on existential
comics right there's this like scale of
difficulty that he has for philosophy
and it gives examples and at the very
top of the scale is instead of like
being highest difficulty it's just Hegel
and I think that if anybody else
deserves to like be at that spot with
him
it's a Whitehead so a really interesting
guy alright so I'm going a little bit
over time but I don't have any problem
with that let me see what else we got
here South keen writes I did dump
Russell as per your recommendation to
start reading the individual dialogues
Russell was pretty biased I did notice
that after a couple hundred pages yeah I
mean Russell you know same thing there's
a lot of histories of philosophy which
are gonna be skewed in one way or
another and you know I could you read
the Durant's right that's a very common
thing the the you know the story of
philosophy it's a great tale but you're
getting a you know a vision that goes
one way or the other or you know one
that was very popular in the 19th
century
we'll handle bonds history of philosophy
it's you know it's not bad or think
about Hegel boy I wouldn't rely on
Hegel's history of philosophy either
it's really cool to read for Hegel and
to see what he's making of people and
you might get some interesting insights
but but it's not really that close so
this is why we you know we like people
like say cobblestone you know who
although you know cobblestone can be bad
on some people as well they're at least
like sticking closer to the texts and
you know not trying to do quite so much
Oh Chad asks a really interesting
question would you consider doing a
philosophical breakdown on some of
philip k dick work his central theme is
essentially what is reality that's one
of his essential themes what is
what does human is another one yeah so I
actually do have one lecture that I did
in the worlds of speculative fiction
series on philip k dick that that's a
local it's a series I'm doing here
locally partnering with the library
we're actually doing Octavia Butler this
month and her xenogenesis series said I
didn't dick you know to year last year
he was one of my favorite authors he is
one my guilty pleasures
you know when I when I have the time I
go over to the local library and I check
out some of his books I've actually read
everything he's written at this point
but I love which is going back and
rereading the stuff with term goals that
I've always wanted to do and I don't
know if it's ever going to happen
this might be something I should
crowdfund actually is to write a book
philip k dick works and all of the
references to different philosophical
theological or psychological concepts
say what those are and say what dick is
actually doing with them because
sometimes he brings them in and he has
his character there's like get them
wrong and then another character correct
them or do something you know
interpreting them and going further with
it so yeah that's one thing I they
actually also taught I thought about
getting an online course like a you know
get in in the the reason I have
teachable Academy we focus specifically
on philip k dick works and talking about
philosophy through that so I you know
that is all a matter of finding the time
to do it though so so here is actually
kind of a timely thing and I can't read
thoroughly so I'm sure I'm mangling the
name or on perhaps how to donate some
money in order to support your channel
I'll actually put the link here you can
go to patriot
and it's just you know patreon.com slash
Sadler that is what people can use to
support and I'm very happy for anybody
who does that because it helps me
actually earn a living doing what I like
now here's the the question before that
what can you tell about a logical
positivism and the truth deflation
theory so logical positivism was was a
movement that was quite popular in
England and you know certain parts of
Europe and then it became popular here
in the United States too for a while and
the idea was that there are two really
important aspects to it one really no
let me backtrack three important aspects
one was the idea that the philosophy was
supposed to be sort of an ancillary to
science to positive knowledge that's the
positivism in it which was coming out of
the 19th century with Spencer and Colt
and people like that for instance - what
does the empirical research tell us you
know and philosophy should have been
essentially you know clarify what
scientists are doing and get its nose
out of things where it's not really
scientific like you know religion ethics
thing things along those lines the other
thing that got connected with that was
you know for its Vera fication and then
falsification as being tests for whether
statements were meaningful and then what
was the third thing
oh yeah the distinction between
empirical or you know or verifiable
statement it's the falsifiable
statements and merely analytic or
tautological you know statements that
was was also part of it so it was
connected with philosophy language and
you know it doesn't have a lot of
adherents today in part because there
are some real problems with it but you
still see people adopting stances
similar to it around do you have any
thoughts on Russo's claim that festivals
contribute to moral decay
particularly in his letter to Dalembert
and I suppose to some degree interest
this course that I don't actually know
but I mean Lisette seemed like something
that that Rousseau you know would have
gotten some mileage out of
perhaps I mean you think about his
depiction of civilized society is you
know essentially corrupting the human
being I think that kind of makes sense
but again I am I'd have to go back and
take a look at the texts how do you feel
about philosophy education in high
school and high school student has
gotten into philosophy I'm disappointed
to find there aren't any classes yeah I
I think that we well so let me say two
things a fine class is in some high
schools here in the United States they
will either invariably be Christian
schools where it's a religion elective
or they will be very well funded public
schools where it will be a social
studies elective and everybody else is
kind of screwed in that respect and even
if you have it there it may not be
taught very well the other thing to say
is yeah we we really want to have
philosophy classes yeah and we probably
never will in part because the
educational establishment has just such
a lock on what gets done so the only
real way to do that this is to come in
from the outside and there are
organizations like Plato
you know just PL ATO that is devoted to
like bringing philosophy into schools
and we're actually trying to work on
some initiatives here in the Milwaukee
area for it for that sort of thing now
you know it would be interesting to
think about online classes for that
would be something that could be quite
good you know that that I don't know
that's worth thinking about
i Caviezel asks a question our humans
intrinsically evil or have we fallen
from grace you know to play on a joke
from Liam Irvine why not
both yeah well I don't I don't know why
it has to be hoses the only exclusive
options you know I I don't think that
we're intrinsically evil I don't think
that we're trinsic ly good either
and I mean so many different things
depending on what theology you've got
Alexa writes dr. Taylor can you touch on
or give an overview of the philosophy of
mathematics I don't think it becomes
important until you're doing very
rigorous stuff yeah I haven't done
anything with that for years and years
and years I was a mathematics and
philosophy major back at under grant and
but I haven't really done anything with
that for a very long time you know I
would say it doesn't involve questions
like well what what are numbers you know
there's this notion of like you know
Platonism numbers are something that
actually exists or are they just you
know formal aspects of our language Mill
thought you could actually develop sort
of empirical approach to that you know
there's other things like well what's
going on with probability that that's
part of philosophy of mathematics try to
remember what are other key ideas come
up what's going on when we're doing
mathematics but again it's not something
I've looked at for a long time a very
funny question thank you so much any
thoughts and their newly found celebrity
status well I wouldn't say I have
celebrity status so I've been doing this
now for six years and I have thousand
subscribers on YouTube somebody can
basically crap out make up videos or cat
videos or very short philosophy videos
and get millions of subscribers not
exactly celebrity status if I am it's
it's only in very small circles you know
and occasionally it leads to getting you
know a free beer or a coffee or
something like that when I meet up with
somebody and it also leads to going to
conferences and people being like I know
you from somewhere but
it's nowhere near celebrity status so
let's see here Bruno writes film scholar
here any favorite films or film makers
[Music]
yeah I guess you could say that you know
I am a fan of Ridley Scott I mean I'm
not really a director Kenny guy I'm more
like I like this film or I like that
film because my favorite film of all
time is a Ridley Scott film it's one of
his earliest ones the duelists
it's got Peter Carradine I was a Keith
Carradine the one who didn't do kung fu
and Harvey Keitel as these Napoleonic
officers who are dueling across the
entire time of the Napoleonic Wars just
beautiful music beautiful backgrounds
really good fighting scenes you know as
a kid I really loved the three
musketeers of the four musketeers the
1970s version with you know Peter yorck
as d'Artagnan and you know Oh Faye
Dunaway is milady de winter so yeah I
didn't you can see a theme there of I
like airing do and swordplay what have I
seen that I've been really impressed by
lately it's hard to say you know I don't
I don't do that much stuff with film I
used to show some some movies in
philosophy classes like I used
mattresses and of Emily Rose in
philosophy religion and Dark City and
memento and intro classes on time since
I've actually done that it's something I
don't spend enough time on quite frankly
Jesus rights as anyone in chant
reference the dude yet yes many times
and it's Oh Belle hazard giving me tips
on burnout yes try not to prefer now I
think that's a great question because
it's something I have to avoid myself so
this is where stoicism can
really dissociating your your
intentionality from you know from the
outcome and valuing what happens in
terms of the outcome just thinking in
terms of doing the action itself for
that for the good of what it is that
you're doing but a good bit you know try
to avoid people who are Downers
sometimes that involves you know
lessening or you're cutting out their
influence in your life and you know
trying to do the sort of things that you
know are going to be conducive to having
a decent life actually you know for my
wife points out that I'm happier when I
do play the banjo I'm pointing over
there cuz the banjos over there fairly
frequently and more of because for me
music is quite important let's see here
a retro gamer you already put online
course in your output that's just not a
curriculum linking the videos and some
meaningful sequence well actually I have
a the reason I am Academy all you gotta
do is like go to teachable let me
actually I don't have many courses there
yet but I actually do have some and I'm
gonna be bringing out more fairly soon
yeah teachable is where I put my and in
there you actually do have a curriculum
not only linking the videos by providing
handouts lesson pages quizzes all sorts
of other cool resources so that's that
Kyle asks have you read Satoshi
nakamoto's Bitcoin white paper I have
not I don't know much about Bitcoin
other than what my my computer science
friends tell me who are into it doing
stuff with it
so and at this point it looks like it's
far too late to get into the game so
that's something that I'm planning on
doing anything with so well it's not
reason I slash show it's it's all one
word reason IO is the name of my company
and I put the link there as well so I'll
take this last question and then I'm
gonna ramp up because it's actually
almost half an hour past what is the
most widespread an accepted theory of
causality and academic philosophy does
everyone criticize humans approach to
causality that causality is not part of
our empirical experience I don't think
there is any most widespread and
accepted theory of causality I don't
know that they're that there's like a
consensus of about that does everybody
sighs humans approach no I mean there's
there's nothing that everybody in
philosophy does to their area you could
that's one of the things about
philosophy you can usually find a number
of people adopting a number of different
perspectives so yeah that's not a easy
one to answer so I'll end on this one
then cuz it's not great to end on not
being able to give an answer this is
from TJ F hey dr. s wonderful work any
tips you can give to prospective grad
students in philosophy I'm actually in
the process of applying to graduate
schools throughout December and early
January yeah when you go in you know try
this is sort of along the same advice
that was giving to the student who's
going to University of Toronto trying to
take as wide a range of classes as
possible you know don't get suckered
into doing all sorts of extra work for
somebody for free and you know
definitely don't burn any bridges based
on ideological differences that you may
not be holding three years down the line
your job as a graduate student is
essentially to learn as much as you can
and actually have the answers on
anything not to produce wonderful you
know publishable paper is certainly not
at a masters level it's about and as you
can because that's the one time in your
life that you actually get the
opportunity to be a student and study
and to not have to like you know I mean
you might have to do some teaching but
you won't be teaching as much as as a
professor one or hustling or whatever
else that you got to do so I'm gonna
wish everybody here a great rest of
December I will be doing another one of
these on my Facebook page later on in
December I do you know one you know
Facebook so I've got to get to some some
work and some grading and some other
things and I hope all of you have a
great weekend